all so let's start uh hello nice to meet
you
i'm misako from tokyo cherry blossom is
fully blooming now
and welcome to design singapore council
market
entry webinar for japan as you may know
designs the rapport council is
singapore's
national agency focusing on developing
and
promoting singapore design sector as
part of
an ongoing effort to provide resources
that support the singaporean singapore
design community
that design singapore council has put
together a series
on of market entry webinars including
today's market anti-webinar for the
japan market
if you are keen to internationalize your
design business
please stay until the end of today's
session to learn more about
council's business of design program
as we as other resources that might be
useful
for your business when it comes to
expanding to other markets
today um this is me presenting about
japanese market
so let me share my screen
this is my presentation today
and please do not hesitate to post any
comments on chat
so that i can correct all the all the
questions for the q and a later on
um please let me know if somebody don't
see my screen
it should be okay okay
so let's start um
today i would like to present japan
market introduction to you
the singapore design forms
including general information contract
and little bit of lifestyle and
furniture
here are the topics you will hear today
so first of all i want to talk about my
company
and then an introduction to market
information
including uh general information about
japan
for design pharmacy in singapore and
how to work successfully with japanese
companies and the individuals
and i also want to touch the trends with
cobit 19
on contract projects then
i would like to talk about contract
project in general
this is all about power games between
designers manufacturers and trading
companies
and then furniture and lifestyle
then last of all affairs in japan and we
can
have the q a session
so before starting the webinar let me
introduce
our company and myself
i'm misako from the company called inu
our company inu just started last year
during covet 19 situation
inu maybe some some people might know
but in means dog
in japanese and i put the name dog
because
dog is an animal which is lawyer hard
worker
sweet and there's a quote good luck may
come
when dog walks in japanese
we establish the company to support
design farms
design industry and communities
and currently we are supporting some
manufacturers
designers so let me come back to the
examples
later and
i i also want to introduce myself
let me speak about myself my name is
misako
um very unfortunate but i am not trained
as a designer
but the trader my first career
was with uh itoji corporation which is
the
one of the biggest uh trading company in
japan
and i was trading tuna fish
for candy tuna and
as i had to trade tuna fish all the time
i started visiting architecture and
design stores
in my free time which unexpectedly
connects myself to next career
then i um there's any
like fortunate that i joined quadra
the dennis texta company for interior
which is also in singapore
i joined the quadra japan as one of the
first members
where i met many players in design
industries
so it is very fortunate to for me to
keep supporting our clients
manufacturers
and designers at being
inu from last year
you can see there are my main clients
and collaborators for us
not only architecture studios and
manufacturers
you can see our business areas expands
to lifestyles such as apex panasonic and
obigoy
the crowdfunding company let me tell you
a little bit about our main clients
as you may not be familiar with japanese
companies
in this industry
the first one is kokuyo i think they
have the subsidiary in singapore too
one of the largest office furniture and
stationery company
we are helping on building their
collection called brand correction
they are trading with um external
brands from overseas
we do design research communication with
international furniture manufacturers
and plan trainings for internals to
to get the employees more understand
more information about the design
furniture
let's move on to karimoku maybe you know
because there are some
dealers in singapore as well karimoku is
one of the biggest udem furniture
manufacturers
miya nagoya we were appointed to promote
kalimoku
to contract market through new space in
tokyo
here's some examples karimoko had worked
recently
so not only the furniture for home
they are trying to expand their business
to contract market
we also support our architecture studio
kcs is our design
they work across architecture interior
and products
and we support them to to get new
business development
and pl press and communications
finally i would like to add naoki terada
he is a product designer based in tokyo
we support
him to conduct webinars with him
and some of the communications
you can see on the right side you can
see the
the ice cream spoons currently his
package
is exhibited in the hungry design
exhibition at design singapore council
until 31st march so if you have time
please visit and
see his design as well
okay now uh let's move on to japan
topics
maybe some of you have been to japan
already but japan is number 11's most
populous country in the world
as well as one of the most densely
populated
and urbanized 125 million people
and three hundred three three thirty
four people square kilometer
which is nothing number 24 meanwhile
singapore
is 5.7 million people but um
7 900 people square kilometers so it's a
little bit
different between us and
tokyo is the most densely city
37 million people which
i am pointing and next to
tokyo there are three kitties which is
also dense
who are trying to commute to tokyo
and then um we see osaka area
and nagoya area and fukuoka area which
are urbanized
and populated the most
and we are divided into 47
administrative prefectures
and eight traditional legions
and we are known for the
forest area is quite high uh lankin
number 21 so 67 percent of the land
is forest and most of
uh half of the forest are planted after
world war
ii i'm going to talk about a little bit
more about that
but meanwhile uh forests uh in singapore
is only three percent
and then uh i would like to talk about
global gender gap index
uh 2020 we are getting lower and lower
every year unfortunately so we are
lunked
a 121 of all the 153 countries
and we are we are speaking japanese and
currency is japanese yen
okay now now i would like to talk
how to work successfully with japanese
companies
and the individuals in japan when you
think about expanding your business to
to
overseas like japan maybe it's nice to
know
um how to work successfully
with japanese people we have a deep
cultural aspect
so i would like to mention that cultural
aspects that
you should know before coming into japan
market
let's see so we are particular about
starting time
it should be always on time but
uh we are not on we are uncertain about
ending time so
meaning that we have longer working
hours
and drinking after work as a habit
and harmony is the greatest of
so it's very important sense of
decision making system and seniority
system
and language barrier introverted
let's talk about time so
i'm i'm sometimes very late to the
meetings but
starting time or meeting time should be
on time
and when i'm when i get
to get to the meeting like one or two
minutes late
then everybody looks at me because
everybody is trying to
to arrive on their sheet uh five minutes
before the meeting
so it is critical to be on time
otherwise
ones get lost their trust sometimes
so be careful so ending time is
uncertain
long working hours because
we are kind of educated that we can't go
home without
senior going home so sometimes the
juniors
are waiting that seniors are going home
but it's it's much less now after it
happened because nobody is going
nearly going to office so it's getting
better
and it's also now less but still
um people really love to go
drinking after work so decisions are
often made while they are drinking after
work
so i'm i'm going to talk
how to deal with this but um
this is a kind of their happiness
in a way to get the teamwork
and i want to talk about harmony
and seniority system
one of the most important barriers of
japanese culture
group is group harmony
we call it
this is prioritized the needs of society
rather than personal interests or
opinions
and to make everybody happy
we keep doing we keep meeting we keep
having meetings to everybody agrees
on the idea so we maybe
can be seen very slow on decision-making
but once we decide the
we decide then we go
and then uh there are there are the
system called
nene kojoretsu main culture to
is respect and barrier on seniority
so i can say that japanese people tend
not to quit the job i heart that
um average wise japanese people
only change their job 2.4 times
in their lifetime because they can be
respected
and buried once they work longer than
other people so that um
a seniority based wage and the promotion
system
creates the lingua direct system as well
so it's very nice to remember people
still
try to work longer
and this is also interesting that
um we sometimes are say
that we have longest barrier and
introverted because of the
japanese language even uh japanese
and singaporean passports offer the most
visa-free travel
that we i mean you and me
can travel a 190 countries
without having visa however
japanese people only have uh 23 percent
of japanese
have the past passport in 2019
and even 40s there are only 21 percent
of the people
holding passport bs under 20s
uh 32 percent
and we also can say that we have a big
language barrier because knowledge of
english
we have the test of english as a foreign
language
planking is 26
in asian 29 countries
which is quite low and
i don't see so many people speak english
still
especially in this industry
however i think it is
interesting to to work with japanese
people
like uh very
similar sometimes but very different in
culture
so my recommendations my tips for you
is it's quite difficult for me but
for me too but you should be on time
and if you are invited to drink after
work
maybe you can accompany them sometimes
so that they
try to communicate after work more
culturally
and you can get closer with them
and don't get annoyed with small yes
because um you should know that japanese
people
have to make a big yes uh
having meetings everybody feels happy
so it takes so much time so don't get
annoyed
because you have to build up the small
yes with many people
and be patient it's it's related be
patient
lay back and see how the decisions are
made
you even i don't see
how the decisions are made in the
client's company
so each company has its own way to make
the decisions
however it doesn't mean that you don't
need to push
but you have to push a nicely but
directory
it's nice because you're a foreigner and
it's always nice to communicate
and i'm known that i'm very directly
pushing
people to make decisions
and learn some japanese words to
communicate
i think japanese language is quite
complicated but maybe
it's nice to learn some greetings
or wars to communicate that's
that's a kind of fast but very important
step
to be closer to japanese people
working with a singaporean designer let
me show a good
example how the singaporean designer
gabriel tan
has worked with japan two japanese
companies
maybe some of you know the brand called
aryake
which is creative directed by gabriel
tan
this is founded by lagnatek and here the
chair
two companies from the fanuc production
town
of morodomi in saga which is the south
area of japan named after the aryakushi
in southern japan area means daybreak in
japanese
it symbolizes a new chapter of two
companies to factories
as they embark on the collaboration with
international designer for the global
market
so i have supported his
workshop that he organizes
every year with the product designers
related to aryake
and when i was it was when i was working
at the techystar company
and i could see that gabriel
uh tried to spend so much time and stay
near this factory for some weeks
with design art and even he tries to
build that built the brand together with
the factory guys
so they i could see the guys
uh accepted welcome gabriel so much
and i think w became the member of the
the two companies so they were very late
on what gabriel said and gabrielle
um invited many international designers
as you can see in the picture
and it took some years to
to grow the plant but i can see
the aryake brand in tokyo in saga
and many people are trying to specify
the
plant in the contract market so i think
um the furniture brand should take
two three years to be recognized in
japan
but this is a good example
okay now i would like to mention about
the trends with covet 19
on contract project
i have listed six categories
office home forest
tourism retail hospitality and fabric
so let's see the office section first
nato vacancy in tokyo increases for
almost a year
companies reducing working area they
think in the sense of belongings
so more lounge area is coming for the
office design
so after the copy happened some
companies moving out from tokyo
for example you can see the picture
persona
the hr um hr
outsourcing company is moving to aoji
island which is 500 kilometer away from
tokyo
and they are making a huge office spirit
for 2 200 people
and things the glasses company is
trying to move little by little to
maiabashi
a little hundred kilometers north than
tokyo
so they will have two headquarters and
amuse the entertainment company
is also moving to yamanasi so little
more and more we hear more about the
news that people are trying to move out
from tokyo
and also some companies uh notice
after the corporate that employees
can have the focusing time in their home
working from home so they are trying to
um so 21 of all the companies are
thinking to reduce office skill
so the big ones like fujitsu is trying
to reduce to 50 percent
the game companies reduces to 60 percent
less focusing area however it
e-commerce companies sometimes tends to
expand
because they are more popular
the e-commerce is being popular after
copied 19.
so there is some there are some examples
about the
design of the coverage 19 situation so
more lounge area
are required and um
so
this is to increase the sense of
belongings to the office
some some designers tend to offer more
greens inside
sometimes stands for camp to casualize
the office
to get together and talk and discuss
and also we don't know we are not sure
about how many people
are going to work in this office
the designers needed to give the space
more flexibility
so movable furnitures are specified more
in the office after kobit 19 situation
so in this bridgestone office this
is everything can be moved so you can
have the big meeting room
or you can just have chairs and you can
stock all the chairs
which is like more you can you can use
it as a
lounge area
and home we have serious problems
with working from home i don't know in
singapore
but we normally live in a very very
small house
that we don't have a space to walk from
and out immigration from tokyo late is
uh increasing like 10 to 70 percent
in 2020 ps 2019
and more innovation market
the design magazine access api 2020
they made a special feature ultra
connected
local communities talking about
designers design communities move out
from tokyo and
start something in the countryside
so there are there's a map of
which that started
after the tokyo creative people move to
the
local area
then let's move to retail
so as for tourism number of tourists
decreased a lot
we don't have foreigners coming to
japan but more inco ecommerce
for national people but
our department stores sell in decreased
a lot
so little existing business model is no
longer popular i can say
however the international luxury plant
are opening their flagship store in
india
the most popular area in japan
so this elmest and louis vuitton
designed by juneau key
were opened this month so
more more of the luxury shops
are opening soon i heard
same hospitality um so we expected
the olympics in 2020 last year
we expected more tourists in fact
600 hotels opened last five years
in 2020 many design hotels
opened but many of them had to cross
their business
just to adjust after their opening
because of the corona
not only in tokyo kyoto is known for the
nice little hotels but
last year 518 hotels
opened in kyoto but 580
hotels were closed down i also would
like to mention about the some
design hotel which you had innovated
from old buildings
outside of tokyo area
in 2020 so left
is shiroya hotel which is 100 kilometer
far from tokyo was renovated from 300
years building
by sofishimoto and the night one is also
a very old house renovated into a hotel
also big hotels luxury hotels are
planned to open
in 2021 to 20 2023
for example double hotel osaka
you can see the knight and pokemirano
in shinjuku in 2023
and tokyo torch tower also in 2023
and i can see many of the innovation
hotels outside of tokyo
are also planned and mainly
hoshinoya the japanese ryokan group is
working on the
projects
not only this such as burgundy hotel
w hotel hyatt hilton marriott group
mainly in tokyo but also okinawa
miseko and in hokkaido will be the next
gen
destinations because people are not
tends to
stay in the avon series and trying to go
out
from tokyo
let me talk a little bit about a
contract project
if you wishing to come into japanese
market
you should know the there is a big power
games between designers manufacturers
and trading companies
from beginning to the end there are many
many stakeholders
involved in one project i think this is
same
in singapore so it is very important to
know who
are the most powerful and who are the
key
to the to convince the design you have
because sometimes it is very possible
that
the project management company or
contract leaders
are the most powerful when the designers
are not powerful enough
so i it's a very simple
recommendation from me that uh not so
many people are speaking in english
so if you want to go into the japanese
market
maybe you can start finding a japanese
partner to work with
so that you can learn about how the
japanese
business how this contract market
move and also to communicate with
with them well
so another example for contract project
in japan
i have been working with norm architects
from denmark
teamed up with kjsl design worked on an
innovation project
this is uh you can see the right
two pictures this is an innovation
project called
uh kinota teras nested in wearing
complex of
36 mesonet built in 1991
and this is in tokyo and two metal nets
they were in charge of one each
so they renovated a room
into a very beautiful missile net
and this was good because normal
architect's design language
fit into japanese contract market
because they
teamed up with casey asizawa who speaks
fluent japanese
and who handles in a way
convince people to renovate well enough
to express no marketing design world
so i think this is great to have
japanese team you
almost can call friend to work with
let me touch a little bit about
lifestyle wooden furniture in japan
there's so much talk so much to talk but
let me just mention the
entry information
so japan is known for traditional crafts
when we talk about the traditional clubs
of japan
we always recognize our culture combines
influence from asia but nowadays
influence from europe and north america
and traditional japanese art when i say
that
it includes class such as ceramics
textile lacquerware sword and dolls
which are not bought so often in these
days
so there are some of the companies
trying to
adjust more modern with traditional
craftsmanship techniques
and they try to be international so for
example the
ceramics in the saga area where i am
pointing
is trying to trying to collaborate with
international designers and sell to
international markets
in japan um we
we maybe we are known for uh wooden
furniture
but we have a very short history in
furniture making
the general public were not using chairs
by around
1950s 60s
because we are living on the tatami
so that we so that the uten furniture
manufacturer have a
short history most of all
have from 1940s
so many small mid-scale manufacturers
are trying to expand
to international market collaborating
with product designers after 2010
because foreign people
are used to have chairs more than
japanese people but also the crafts that
we have
it's quite um beautiful
and all the almost of the all
manufacturers
have the same challenge for sdgs that
we have the forest area of 67 percent
of the land however uh 40 percent of the
whole forest are planted forest after
world war ii which is
after 1945
which we needed more food to build
houses to burn things
so um ninety percent of the
trees in the planted forest is
pony fellows trees which is softer than
the
oak or walnuts
which is very difficult to make the
chairs
however all the uten function
manufacturers are tend to
use the company's trees like sugi
pinocchi like japanese ones to
achieve this sdgs challenge
this is the last part first of all i
would like to introduce
funny giant lifestyle fairs in japan
that's the schedule of affairs
recommended for international designers
let's look into the fairs one by one if
you are furniture designers
i would recommend you to visit the
asahikawa design week
and international furniture design fair
asahikawa as not only 50 of
wooden furniture manufacturers in that
area participate
but also many of them from other areas
are joining
and you will get so many opportunities
to get closer to the manufacturers
and number of resistors um 18
000 people which is not included
uh the local people
and in next is interior lifestyle care
and iffd which are organized by the same
organization
so in may you will see the lifestyle
goods ceramics and clocks for may
and more furnitures are for october
they also offer booths for designers to
exhibit in the hall
so you can meet with the manufacturers
but also the the japanese designers
in the fair
and the last one is design art the diner
is hold in the center of tokyo aiming to
show creations and concepts
across all germs of design and art
so fabric are freely touring along to
see the exhibition for two weeks
and they count 140 000 people
are visiting the
exhibitions
okay that is all from me
um you very much for listening my
presentation
i hope you enjoyed and something new to
you
before i open the floor for the q a
session
we want you we want to bring your
attention to the screen
for those interested in getting to know
more about design singapore council
business of design program i would
also like to introduce mobile from the
council
who will share more about the business
of design program
so let me change
oh okay the face model
yes thank you thanks mistake and thank
you everyone for
taking the time to join us on this rainy
monday afternoon
so as misako has mentioned i'd like to
take this chance to share more about the
business of design program
or the bod program so the beaut program
aims to grow the export value of
singapore designs
through building mindshare in both
business to business and business to
consumer markets around the world
this two-year long program will address
targeted aspects
of developing the capabilities of
participating design firms
this includes mentorship access to
networks and brand storytelling
to increase their competitiveness and
demand on a global stage
so we are now going to have the second
round of the bod program and this run
aims to generate new business
opportunities for up to eight
established singapore design studios and
brands
with the potential to internationalize
in markets such as europe and asia so
this includes japan and southeast asia
so to grow businesses and propel them
globally the bod program encompasses
three key phases
for the first phase dsu will appoint a
panel of in-market consultants
to guide design studios and brands in
their pitch to secure
overseas business opportunities the
consultants will also connect
participating design students and brands
to relevant business circles while
providing mentorship for follow-through
these business circles or leads include
property owners and specifiers for those
who are seeking commercial contract
projects
brands and manufacturers for those
seeking consultancy projects
and global or regional retailers and
distributors for those who are seeking
buyers
these consultants will be selected based
on their networks and influence and are
expected to have convertible business
leads in their markets
the second phase comprises participants
potentially being provided funding to
engage a brand strategy agency
this will help to enforce quality
perception of their brand so as to
facilitate stronger recall
dsg will also organize a series of media
training sessions for participating
design firms
the support for the second phase will be
provided on a co-funding basis
lastly the beauty program will culminate
in a themed collective showcase at an
international
showcase platform in 2022 and
working in conjunction with the
in-market consultants this approach will
raise the international standing of
singapore design
and interest buyers from target markets
in asia and europe
to support interested design firms that
are keen to internationalize in
understanding the commitment required in
the new markets
dsg is co-organizing a series of market
entry webinars
including today's session in addition to
the body program
these webinars are also part of an
ongoing effort to
find resources that support the
singapore design community
so the open call for brdd participants
is currently open and it'll close on
22nd april
let me just quickly run through the
eligibility and selection criteria for
the program
so in terms of the eligibility criteria
the applicant must be a single
registered design enterprise from any of
the following fields
furniture and lifestyle product design
studios multi-disciplinary design
studios that cover furniture and
livestock product design as a part of
their offering
and design driven furniture and all
lifestyle product brands that work with
singapore designers to launch product
lines
the lead applicant must also be a
singapore citizen or permanent resident
in terms of the selection criteria the
bod program prioritizes
established design studios and brands
which fulfill the following criteria
having a compelling and different shades
of brand philosophy and aspiring towards
good design
which impacts positively on the
environment culture society or the
economy
having strong business fundamentals and
being ready to scale up to meet
international demand
so to do so the participant must for
example operate with a sound business
model
and have sufficient resources or be
prepared to scale through a network of
production partners
lastly having a good understanding of
the commitment required to enter
a new market so because of this we
strongly encourage interested applicants
to attend the market entry webinars for
the markets that they're keen to expand
into so i hope this sharing provides
a good idea of what the business of
design program is about and for more
information about the body program
as well as the upcoming market entry
webinar we have later today on the
european market please scan the qr code
i will now have now pass the time back
to mistake for the q a session
thank you marvel it was interesting so
together with design singapore team we
are looking forward to
the boards supporting and meeting the
design farms in singapore like you
to get into the japan market together
now we would like to move forward to the
q a sessions
so if you have any questions just
post on the chat
area and i see one two questions
um so also thank you for your
question and what do i mean by a small
yes
and a big yes this is very good question
because
i don't think not so many people have it
but
um so maybe i should
share my screen again
oh
so small yes and uh
big yes means that uh
in general not not everyone but in
general
we do like communicate with designers
and we are quite positive in many ways
so for example um juniors
talking with designers and they are
always
saying yes that design is very nice
we love it we want to work on this
however maybe you can experience that
the project
never go going forward because um
this is this is the states that you
don't have a big
yes because um the decision should be
made
with under the name of harmony
so the junior has to the has to
bring the small yes to the seniors to
make the big yes
so it goes if if you're working with big
big companies
then you will get like five or six
layers of small
yes then you have to correct these
smallers to make the yes bigger and
bigger
that is one of the the
the hardest part that you will see
that you don't know where to believe in
a way
but don't worry if you hear yes
maybe you can just directly ask um
what can i do next with you then
maybe you can build the project together
with the juniors
up to the seniors and i also recommend
to communicate with the business owners
if you if you can
then you can go from the
down and from the app so you can
in a way shortcut the your project
to become email
and
[Music]
what are the consideration for singapore
plan to be aware
of with regards to shipping furniture to
japan for example certification and
standards
and other considerations for the
japanese customs
ooh good question
maybe i have to come back to you for the
the for the customs because i think
this is depending on the items
and also how you export
so maybe i can come back through
model the design singapore team
later but thank you for your question
and wendy
oh thank you for your for your question
and thank you for the insight for
sharing
thank you for listening and from my
experience
it takes time to build trust with
japanese clients and partners
do you think it is realistic to expect
business outcomes in two years under bod
framework good question and
i think this is all about
how you make the short card
and also if you have a good
friend who recommends you as a designer
maybe it can be much shorter that's why
i think i'm going to support
with with with design singapore the
singaporean designers
and within two years i think lifestyle
items should be easier to be
uh to be seeing the outcomes but
furnitures it's depending on the
deadline
that manufacturers carry sometimes they
have the
like a pop-up project which
are trying to achieve some sdgs
projects
am i answering my your question
wendy
yeah but let me let me try my best to
support you
you guys
um sorry mabel here yes um i think i i
should also add um is one of the
market consultants for the business of
design programs so
um if you're keen to work in a japanese
market and you have any questions about
the business of design program
um feel free to email us later um if you
have any any questions
yeah and as miss aqua said um you know
it might be
um two years uh maybe enough for
lifestyle products you mentioned in saco
um but maybe a bit more challenging for
furniture but then with
um you know connections to the business
circles that um has then you know that
might be
a shortcut as she mentioned yeah thank
you
yeah and i would like to add if the
contract project
i see normally offices are completed
after six to nine months and hotels
maybe three years so it's going to be
difficult for hotels but it's going to
be
okay for office interior
and cafe retail shops
any more questions
so okay thank you for thank you for your
questions
um also please remember to take part in
post event survey and end of webinar
so yeah so this is all
um this is under hobbit situation still
but i am very much looking forward to
seeing you
after this situation comes down so thank
you
thank you very much again for your time
today and please have a lovely evening
thank you thank you miss alko and thanks
everyone for joining us
you